hallo deutsch schule punkt ch hören und
nachsprechen lektion 4 hört zu und
spricht nach welche farbe hat die jacke
welche farbe hat die jacke sie ist rot
sie ist rot welche farbe hat der
rucksack welche farbe hat der rucksack
er ist grün
welche farbe hat das handy welches
erbe hat das handy es ist schwarz es ist
schwarz welche farbe haben die schuhe
welche farbe haben die schuhe
sie sind braun
wie viel kostet das kleid wie
die kostet das kleid es kostet 149
franken
es kostet 149 franken wie viel
kostet der pullover wie viel kostet der
pullover er kostet 87 franken
er kostet 87 franken
wie viel kosten die tabletten wie viel
kosten die tabletten
sie kosten 14 franken 30
wie viel kostet die schere wie
viel kostet die schere sie kostet 6
franken 80
sie kostet 6 franken 80 9 franken für
ein bier ist teuer
9 franken für ein bier ist teuer
der kaffee ist heißer kaffee ist heiß
der wein ist sauer
[Musik]
vitamine sind gesund vitamine
und gesund die schokolade ist süß die
schokolade ist süß das buch die bücher
das buch die bücher die tasse die passen
die tasse die tassen
der rocker der
die röcke der schuh
der schuh die schule das t shirt die t
shirts das t shirt die t shirts das
das alt alt der tag der tat falsch
falsch
[Musik]
rot-rot wo ordnen ordnen kommen kommen
der sohn der sohn du du gut und und und
super super das buch das buch lernen
lernen
der lehrer der lehrer welche welche
lediglich
[Musik]
ich bin bin richtig richtig mir mir